sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor zwei Wochen
hat hier dieser Stelle der Bundeskanzler
in einer Generaldebatte ein großes Wort
in den Mund genommen er hat vom
Deutschland Pakt gesprochen in der Mitte
dieses Parlamentes ich habe ihm direkt
darauf geantwortet dass wir zur
Verfügung stehen die größte aktuelle
Herausforderung der Zeit die
migrationskrise in einem Deutschland
packt mit ihm zu bewältigen seitdem ist
allerdings nichts unternommen worden um
diese Worthülse mit Leben zu erfüllen
und deswegen bekommen Sie heute unsere
Antwort den deutschlandpark zum Stopp
der irregulären Migration meine Damen
und Herren
es ist übrigens nicht verständlich war
warum das jetzt in Teilen von ihren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Vorfeld
kritisiert worden ist die Öffentlichkeit
sie hat ein Recht darauf zu erfahren was
in einem Deutschland packt vereinbart
werden kann zum Stopp der
illegalen Migration und deswegen lassen
Sie mich auch zu Beginn dieser Debatte
sagen ein Deutschland packt beinhaltet
nicht das was sie gerne unter sich
beschließen wollen ein Deutschland packt
beinhaltet das was notwendig ist von
ihnen alleine blockiert wird das ist ein
deutschland-
wir bieten Ihnen an dieses Thema mit uns
zu lösen weil es sonst zu einem
gesellschaftlichen Großkonflikt sich
entwickeln kann die Asylzahlen sie
steigen die Kommunen sind überlastet die
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz sie
schwindet wenn das die Analyse ist wenn
das die Grundlage ist dann kann man
daraus einen Konsens bilden wir sind
bereit auf dieser Basis einen Konsens
mit ihnen zu finden
unser ehemalige Bundespräsident Joachim
Gauck hat es am Wochenende eindrucksvoll
formuliert wörtlich hatte gesagt die
bisherigen Maßnahmen reichen nicht aus
um den Kontrollverlust der öffentlich
eingetreten ist zu beheben meine Damen
und Herren also lassen Sie uns neue
Maßnahmen vereinbaren die sichere
herkunftsstaatenregelung sie wird von
den Grünen im Bundesrat blockiert die
Grenzkontrollen nicht nur zu Österreich
sondern wir können Sie auch zu Polen und
Tschechien machen und wir stoppen die
Freiwilligen Aufnahmeprogramme Frau
Ministerin hören Sie auch bitte auf das
außengrenzverfahren in Europa zu
torpedieren sie sind der Grund warum es
nicht besser geht hier mit der Steuerung
der Migration
nein keine Fake News sondern das sind
die Worte der bundesinnenministerin ich
habe sie noch genau im Ohr Frau
bundesinnenministerin sie haben den
Asylkompromiss auf der einen Seite in
Europa gefeiert auf der anderen Seite
haben Sie sofort angekündigt ihn über
das Europaparlament zu torpedieren sie
sitzen auf der europäischen Ebene nicht
im Triebwagen sondern sie sitzen im
bremshäuschen das ist doch die Wahrheit
an der Stelle
gestern hat das Europäische Parlament
die Verhandlungen abgebrochen weil die
Bundesregierung sie Frau Ministerin die
Einigung zur krisenverordnung blockiert
die krisenverordnung ist aber notwendig
damit wir Migranten in den Einrichtungen
an den Außengrenzen unterbringen können
damit man Standards anpassen kann sie
sind diejenige die anstatt Vernunft
Verhalten zu lassen anstatt Solidarität
walten zu lassen diese Entscheidungen in
Europa blockieren in Europa ist Frau
Feser bei der Migrationspolitik kein Zug
fährt sondern sie sind das trojanische
Pferd zu Verschärfung der
migrationskrise das ist die Situation
stellt man keine Gemeinsamkeiten mehr
mit dem falschen Körper
wie haben in der Vergangenheit Frau
Ministerin sie haben in der
Vergangenheit die pull-faktoren weiter
ausgeweitet sie haben mit ihrer
chancenaufenthaltsgesetz mit ihrer
Express Einbürgerung mit ihrem Streichen
des Wortes Begrenzung auf dem
Aufenthaltsgesetz neue pulfaktoren
gesetzt und damit das noch nicht beweist
genug ist sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin
ist heute zu lesen in den Medien dass
sie jetzt überlegen den Familiennachzug
weiter auszuweiten das ist keine Politik
die brems das ist eine Politik die
illegalektion antreibt und fördert
und sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin wenn
Sie jetzt den Eindruck erwecken wollen
übrigens auch gestern in einer
Fernsehsendung dass sie ja bereit waren
bereit sein mehr zu machen aber mit
dieser Koalition ginge das eben nicht
dann sage ich Ihnen hier noch mal eines
wir stehen zur Verfügung dann lösen sie
sich endlich vom grünen Gängelband und
machen Sie einen in Deutschland packt
der mit uns möglich ist und die illegale
Migration zu begrenzen danke schön
Alexander dobrettung Alexander Dobrind
war der erste Redner in der Debatte zu
einem Antrag der Unionsfraktion hatte
sehr häufig die bundesinnenministerin
angesprochen und durch glückliche Fügung
was soll ich sagen ist ja auch die
nächste Rednerin und kann jetzt direkt
reagieren auf den einen und anderen
Vorhalt den Alexander Dobrindt hier
gemacht hat wir sind gespannt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Abgeordnete
sehr verehrte Gäste Liebe Union sehr
geehrte Abgeordneter Dobrindt ich hatte
eigentlich vor am Anfang meiner Rede zu
loben dass sie endlich mal was auf dem
Tisch legen statt diese Sprüche zu
machen aber ihre Rede hat leider wieder
genau das Gegenteil gemacht nämlich nur
angeheizt in der Debatte und ich halte
das angesichts der Lage für unangemessen
ich will das ganz deutlich sagen es ist
unangemessen
denn ja die Herausforderung in der
Migrationspolitik sind große und
deswegen wollte ich eigentlich dafür
loben dass sie mal was vorlegen statt in
der Presse irgendwas zu tun und ich
werte das Herr Dobrindt sie haben es
auch am Anfang gesagt wir müssen erstmal
zuhören ersparen wir haben ja gestern
eine muntere Diskussion dazu gehabt
vielleicht hören Sie mir einfach heute
mal zu
sie haben am Anfang ihrer Rede gesagt
und das nehme ich sehr wohlwollend auch
dass sie die ausgestreckte Hand des
Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz zum
Deutschland packt annehmen um die
irreguläre Migration zu bekämpfen ich
werde das als gutes Zeichen meine Damen
und Herren
und ich habe mit großen Interesse in
ihrem Antrag gelesen ich will das auch
noch mal sagen dass sie von
substanziellen Lösungen dort reden auch
wenn ich daran erinnern möchte dass
Union Innenminister in den 16 Jahren
eben keine substanziellen Lösung
vorgelegt haben meine Damen und Herren
deswegen sollten Sie ein bisschen
bescheidener sein in dieser Debatte
viel wichtiger ist mir was anderes wir
haben als Demokraten eine Verantwortung
für unsere Demokratie gehen Sie nicht
weiter auf dem ihr Weg Wahlkampf auf dem
Rücken von Menschen zu machen die vor
Krieg und Terror bedroht sind meine
Damen und Herren
ja ob das Gerede Herr
Fraktionsvorsitzender märz von
sozialtouristen aus der Ukraine oder das
Remake der Obergrenze von Herrn Söder
all das ist Populismus pur und stärkt
nur die Rechtsextremen
oder ich will Markus Söder selbst
zitieren der einmal gesagt habe du
kannst ein stinkt hier nicht überstinken
machen Sie also denselben Fehler nicht
noch einmal einfache Lösungen zu
präsentieren obwohl es die nicht gibt
meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren ich will über das
reden was Sache ist
über 200.000 Asylanträge wurden in
diesem Jahr bis August bereits gestellt
derzeit leben etwa mehr als eine Million
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine in
Deutschland die sie übrigens mit keinem
Wort hier erwähnt haben zudem hat die
Bundespolizei bis einschließlich juli
56.52 unerlaubte Einreise nach
Deutschland verzeichnet und die letzten
Zahlen zur schleusungskriminalität die
Bundespolizei bis Ende Juli diesen
Jahres circa 1.300 Fälle mit 1400
Schleusern festgestellt diese Zahlen
zeigen ja wir sind auf allen Ebenen
gefordert irreguläre Migration
einzuschränken
und deshalb meine Damen und Herren
arbeitet die Bundesregierung mit den
Kommunen mit den Ländern echten
substanziellen Lösungen das heißt
konkret ich habe die Bundespolizei an
den deutschen Außengrenzen insbesondere
zu Polen in Tschechen mit mehreren
Hundertschaften verstärkt und die machen
erfolgreiche Schleierfahndung dort und
mein Dank gilt den Beamtinnen und
Beamten die wirklich gute Arbeit leisten
Frau Ministerin gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung der
Abgeordneten Polat
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin auch im
Hinblick auf den Antrag der heute uns
vorliegt wird immer von irregulärer
Migration gesprochen und ich glaube sie
meinen damit die unerlaubten einreisen
aber ist es richtig dass diejenigen die
unerlaubt einreisen sobald der
Asylantrag gestellt wird dann eine
Aufenthaltsgestattung bekommen und eben
legal hier in Deutschland sind das ist
richtig Frau Abgeordnete Pollert und
deswegen stimmen die Zahlen die da
kursieren von 300.000 auch nicht
unsere meine Damen und Herren unsere
Schleierfahndung wirken und sind sehr
viele effektiver weil sie dazu führen
dass wir an vielen Stellen an der Grenze
gleichzeitig Kontrollen durchführen
können im Übrigen hätten wir sie
Datenlage auch sonst überhaupt nicht und
meine Damen und Herren von der Union
wollen Sie jetzt eine sachliche Debatte
oder nicht
deswegen habe ich meine Arbeit mit Polen
und Tschechien verstärkt in der
bilateralen Zusammenarbeit wir haben mit
beiden Ländern
gemeinsame Dienststellen wir arbeiten
gemeinsam mit mischten Teams aus
polnischen und deutschen Polizeibeamtin
Beamten mit Tschechien das gleiche und
ich kann Ihnen auch sagen dass dieser
Tage mich die Berichterstattung aus
Polen über Visa-Skandal besorgen
deswegen bin ich mit meinem
innenministerkollegen in Polen auch im
engen Austausch wir haben das im Blick
da können Sie sich darauf verlassen
meine Damen und Herren
und auch ein Wort zur
schleuserkriminalität das ist mir
persönlich ganz wichtig wir reden hier
von Verbrechern die
Menschenleben aufs Spiel setzen die
Bundespolizei befreit regelmäßig Männer
Frauen und Kinder aus entsetzlichen
lagen lebensgefährliche eingepfercht
ohne Wasser ohne Nahrung und mit kaum
Sauerstoff diese Verbrechen müssen wir
verhindern meine Damen und Herren
deshalb handeln wir und dafür haben wir
Sofortmaßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
eine operative zentrale zu Analyse der
schleuserkriminalität bei der
Bundespolizei eine neue Task Force die
wir gemeinsam mit Polen und Tschechien
gründen und wir schließen
strafbarkeitslücken das haben sie
übrigens auch nie gemacht wir weiten die
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten aus Schleusern
ihren Aufenthaltstitel zu entziehen und
sie auszuweisen und das ist wirklich
wichtig meine Damen und Herren auch da
hat die Union übrigens nicht gehandelt
und ja zur
schleuserkriminalitätsbekämpfung kann es
auch partiell notwendig sein stationäre
Grenzkontrollen durchzuführen unsere
Maßnahmen wirken wir steuern und ordnen
Migration meine Damen und Herren wir
unterstützen Länder und Kommunen
substanziell mit
Milliardenbeträgen wir haben Reformen
auf den Weg gebracht die wirken meine
Damen und Herren im Gegensatz zu ihnen
und ich wundere mich schon Herr dobrinz
also wenn ich das noch mal sagen darf
jetzt plötzlich kommen verbindliche
Vereinbarungen um ihre Migrationen die
Aufnahmen geflüchter Menschen zu
reduzieren und sie reden von Europa ich
hätte da was verhindert lieber Herr
Dobrind ich weiß in Europa die für die
Bundesregierung es geschafft hat den
historischen Durchbruch hinzubekommen
dass wir überhaupt eine Lösung haben ein
gemeinsames europäisches Asylsystem auf
dem Weg zu bringen das ist ja lächerlich
was sie hier machen sie haben sich
hinbekommen wir haben es hinbekommen als
Bundesregierung
Frau Ministerin gestatten sie eine
weitere Zwischenfrage oder zwischen
Bemerkung des Kollegen de Vries aus der
cdu/c zu sein
bleiben wir bleiben wir also bei den
Fakten und ja Herr de Fries ich weiß ja
was sie fragen wollen nein die
Bundesregierung verhindert keinen
weiteren Trilog mit dem Europaparlament
wir werden die Verhandlung voranbringen
meine Damen und Herren
schon seit Beginn des Jahres haben wir
ein Gesetz zur Beschleunigung der
asylgerichtsverfahren und Asylverfahren
in Kraft gesetzt wir ermöglichen damit
besseren vor allen Dingen schnellere
Entscheidung und wir entlasten
Verwaltungsgerichte und das BAM um
ausreisen konsequenter umzusetzen sieht
auch unser Koalitionsvertrag eine
rückführungsoffensive zu im Mai hat sich
der Bundeskanzler mit dem
Ministerpräsidentin Ministerpräsidenten
dazu besprochen und ich freue mich ja
dass sie die Dinge im mpk-beschluss vom
10 Mai sämtlich in ihrem Beschluss
aufgeführt haben wir gehen aber deutlich
darüber hinaus meine Damen und Herren
wir haben im Anschluss intensiv mit den
Ländern und Kommunen an zwei
Gesetzesinitiativen gearbeitet mit den
Erkenntnissen daraus haben wir ganz
aktuell zur Verbesserung der Rückführung
finalisiert jetzt geht die
Ressortabstimmung los meine
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter haben heute
morgen auf den Startknopf gedrückt wir
handeln also schon wo sie nur fordern
meine dam Damen und Herren
und ich freue mich meine Damen und
Herren über die Unterstützung denn wir
haben im Bundeskabinett vor ein paar
Wochen sichere herkunftsstanden
ausgewiesen deswegen habe ich mich ein
bisschen gewundert über ihre Worte Herr
Dobrindt nämlich die Republik Moldau und
Georgien und das wird zu einer
deutlichen Entlastung führen bei 10
Prozent der Migranten die einreisen von
dort kommen also wird es schnelle
Entlastung bringen meine Damen und
Herren deswegen wir liefern echte
substanzielle Lösungen sie reden nur
darüber meine Damen und Herren und es
wäre schön
und es wäre schön wenn wir auch die CDU
von damals von Helmut Kohl in der Frage
europäischer Errungenschaften ab und zu
mal wieder hören würden nämlich eine der
größten Errungenschaften der
Europäischen Union was der damalige
Bundeskanzler Helmut Kohl vorgebracht
hat ist die Offenheit unserer
Binnengrenzen meine Damen und Herren das
müssen deshalb auch die Außengrenzen der
EU gestärkt werden
so meine Damen und Herren für die Ampel
kann ich nur sagen wir haben einen
klaren Kurs in der Migrationspolitik
Fachkräfte gewinnen Humanität leben ihre
reguläre Migration beenden wir schützen
das individuelle Grundrecht auf Asyl
auch vor Missbrauch und wir steuern und
ordnen die Migration viel stärker als
bisher damit sichern wir die Zukunft und
die Zusammenhalt in Europa und in
Deutschland vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
vor Alexander Dobrindt aus der
Unionsfraktion nach Annäherung und
gemeinsamer Lösungssuche hat das jetzt
nicht wirklich ausgesehen
Intervention der Kollege de Vries aus
der CDU-Fraktion
Frau Ministerin angesichts ihrer
Performance in der Asylpolitik und auch
ihrem Umgang mit Spitzenbeamten möchte
ich mich im Namen der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion verwehren
dagegen dass sie Bezug nehmen auf Helmut
Kohl das will ich einmal ganz deutlich
sagen
und ich muss schon sagen ihre Rede hat
sehr sehr viel mit Realitätsverlust zu
tun ich möchte von Ihnen mal wissen wie
Asylzahlen sind angestiegen um 78
Prozent stand august im letzten Jahr um
48 Prozent sie explodieren förmlich wir
haben Höchststand an illegalen einreisen
nach Deutschland was hat eigentlich ihre
Rede mit der Realität zu tun diese Frage
möchte ich Ihnen mal gerne stellen und
das zweite ist sie sprechen von
Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung was haben
Sie denn substanziell vorgelegt in ihrer
Amtszeit was in irgendeiner Form die
unkontrollierte Einwanderung nach
Deutschland begrenzt hätte das würde ich
gerne mal von Ihnen hören und die letzte
Frage ist wie kann es sein in einer
solchen Situation dass sie einen
Referentenentwurf in ihrem Ministerium
haben der weiteren Familiennachzug nach
Deutschland ermöglicht bei subsidiär
Geschützen ein Nachtzug von weiteren
100.000 Personen sie wollen den Nachtzug
für Minderjährige unbegleitete
Flüchtlinge mit ihren Angehörigen
erleichtern sie wollen
identitäts-stadtliche Versicherung
abzugeben das ist die Einladung zum
Betrug und was hat das bitte mit Ihrer
Rede zu tun die sie eben gehalten haben
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
danke schön frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Abgeordnete de Fries ich bin
froh dass ich noch mal die Gelegenheit
zu haben auch zu ihrem letzten Punkt
etwas zu sagen das wäre sonst von meiner
Redezeit noch mal abgegangen nein ich
habe nicht vor im Moment den
Familiennachzug vorzulegen darum das
nochmal ganz deutlich zu ich weiß dass
Sie Interesse daran haben Dinge auch in
der Presse zu steuern dieser Tage und
Herr de Fries das Angebot des
Bundeskanzlers gilt ich habe ihnen eben
in zehn Minuten da gelegt was wir schon
alles getan haben zur
asylverfahrensbeschleunigung zu
verstärken Grenzkontrollen zu einer
verstärkten Zusammenarbeit mit Polen und
Tschechien mitten am massiven
Schleierfahndung an den Grenzen und was
unsere Erfolge in Europa betrifft die
ihre Innenminister weder von CSU CDU je
erreicht haben hätte Fries sie müssen
auch einfach in dieser Debatte zuhören
und Sachen auch annehmen meine Damen und
Herren diese Bundesregierung handelt sie
reden nur
wir fahren in der Debatte fort und der
nächste Redner für die afd-fraktion ist
Dr Bernd Baumann
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
gellende Hilferufe aus Italien dort den
Lampedusa landet Boot auf Boot jede
Minute kommt eins alle kommen direkt aus
Afrika alle sind randvoll mit
Schwarzafrikanern und praktisch alle
sind Männer junge Männer Polizisten
versuchen schutzketten zu bilden gegen
die anstörende dahinter stehen die
Einwohner Angst und Schrecken im Gesicht
manche schreien ihre Wut heraus ein
italienischer Bürgermeister sagt was die
übrigen denken das ist eine Invasion das
sind Invasoren aus Afrika und Orient
recht hat er denn die da kommen sind
weiten teils keine Schutz suchenden das
sind Männer vor denen wir Schutz
brauchen wir Europäer in Italien in
Frankreich und vor allem in Deutschland
meine Damen und Herren
denn die Masse zieht ja weiter nach
Deutschland die Zahlen sind gigantisch
Bürgermeister und Landräte aller
Parteien schreien auf aber was unsere
Bürger am meisten quält ist wie viele
dieser Migranten das Bild auf unseren
Straßen verändern jede Woche
gewalttätige Ausschreitungen 10 von
Bandenkrieg
Bürgerkrieg Straßenkampf nicht nur an
Silvester verletzte Polizisten ohne Ende
verängstigte Bürger dazu die wuchernden
Parallelgesellschaften kulturelle
gegengesellschaften mit anderen Frauen
Bildern ganz anderen Vorstellung von
Staat und Gesellschaft überall werden
Frauen bedrängt täglich Frauen und
Mädchen vergewaltigt in Schwimmbädern in
Parks auf offenen Straßen unsere
Bevölkerung und unsere Frauen und
Mädchen an Schutz verdient meine Damen
und Herren
immer mehr Menschen sagen
immer mehr Menschen sagen schlimmer als
der menschengemachte Klimawandel ist der
menschengemachte Bevölkerungswandel
meine Damen und Herren
und diesen Bevölkerungswandel hat die
CDU hat die CDU über Deutschland
hereinbrechen lassen das war ein tiefer
historischer Einschnitt
denn die CDU war doch seit Adenauer
Zeiten immer der Garant konservativer
Politik die stabilisierende Gegenkraft
zu allen linken Spinnereien ich selber
habe die 30 Jahre gewählt aber die CDU
hat ihren alten Kurs verlassen sie haben
ihre eigenen Wähler verraten und dieser
Verrat haftet ihnen an für immer
der innere Verfall der CDU hatte
begonnen als die Linken 68er immer mehr
Bereiche eroberten unsere Medien
Universitäten Kirchen und die
Lehrerschaft als der Zeitgeist sich
änderte zu dem was wir heute den Links
grünen Mainstream nennen da begann die
CDU statt konservativ gegenzuhalten
einzuknicken und mitzumachen sie
schwenkte ihr Fähnchen in den Wind
wollte Deutschland bunter machen
diverser machen mit offenen Grenzen
ungesteuerter millionenwanderung meine
Damen und Herren heute stehen wir vor
den Trümmern dieses katastrophalen links
der CDU das ist was wir heute sehen
und das Volk
ist weiten teils schockiert jetzt sieht
das Volk die Ergebnisse hat die Linken
Spinnereien satt sieht jetzt sieht jetzt
die Ergebnisse besonders in Sachen
Migration alle sehen den zunehmenden
Verlust unserer Sicherheit unseres
Wohlstands unserer Identität den Verlust
unserer Heimat jetzt kippt die Stimmung
im Land das Pendel schlägt zurück von
links nach rechts zur konservativen
Seite dem neuen Zeitgeist und dafür
steht die AFD
deshalb sind wir mittlerweile die
stärkste Kraft in Thüringen in
Brandenburg in Sachsen-Anhalt in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in Brandenburg in
Gesamtdeutschland bereits zweitstärkste
Kraft vor SPD vor den Grünen vor FDP und
Linken und der Union immer dichter auf
den Fersen das ist es was sie antreibt
Herr märz die Angst vor dem neuen
Zeitgeist und Angst vor der AFD
und die Panik der Union sieht man an
ihren heutigen
migrationsantrag sie machen eine Wende
um 180 Grad und übernehmen dabei alle
Positionen der AFD bis ins Detail hier
nur ein paar Beispiele Migranten an der
deutschen Grenze wollen sie zurückweisen
indem sie Dublin 3 umsetzen das haben
wir mehrfach gefordert zuletzt zweiter
2021 sie haben das zurückgewiesen dann
nur noch Sachleistungen statt
Geldleistung für Migranten auch das
haben wir mehrfach gefordert zuletzt
Oktober 22 sie lehnten das ab dann
Familiennachzug begrenzen du lieber Gott
wollten wir schon 2017 sie lehnten ab
Kontrollen an den Binnengrenzen
Kontrollen an den bienengrenzen schon
2017 haben wir das gefordert da hat die
CDU behaupte das ginge überhaupt nicht
man könnte die deutschen Grenzen gar
nicht schützen so haben sie gelogen
damals und
und wegen dieser Position wegen dieser
Position haben sie alle uns als
rechtsradikale beschimpft haben muss sie
Verfassungsschutz auf den Hals geätzt
und heute fordert diese Union dass
selbst das zeigt wie rückgratlos sie
Politik machen während wir als
konservative unseren Werten treu
geblieben sind
der einzige Grund für den öffentlich
inszenierten Richtungswechsel der CDU
ist der Erfolg der AFD aber wer ist denn
eigentlich die AFD das sind gut
30.000 Parteimitglieder tapfere Männer
und Frauen die bereit waren aufzustehen
aufzustehen dem linksgrün Mainstream zu
trotzen viele mussten sich anspucken
lassen beim Flyer verteilen bei Plakate
aufstellen sie sind täglich und täglich
angegriffen worden und sie haben
trotzdem weitergemacht ohne diese
Bewegung der AFD ohne diese Bewegung
gegen den linken Zeitgeist hätten die 10
Millionen Wähler die heute hinter uns
stehen keine politische Heimat niemand
den Sie wählen können keine Hoffnung und
keine Macht die Perspektive haben sie
nur durch die AFD
aber die AFD die AFD diese Affen diese
aufrechten 30.000 die sich nicht haben
beugen lassen haben doch etwas anderes
gezeigt sie haben gezeigt dass unsere
Demokratie
funktioniert
und das ist sich lohnt standhaft zu
bleiben die Union die schwankt doch nur
hin und her die Söders und die Merzen
sind ja nur Fähnchen im Wind aber wir
sind der Wind
Bernd Baumann ist erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion hat gesprochen in einer
Debatte zu einem Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zur Migrationspolitik und
hat sich in einem
überwiegenden Teil seiner Rede mit der
Union beschäftigt nächste Rednerin ist
Katrin Göring-Eckardt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
wenn ich sie reden höre dass wir ein
Land haben das vielfältig ist das offen
ist in dem Werte zählen in dem liberale
konservative fortschrittliche gemeinsam
an den guten Sachen arbeiten wollen und
nicht diese Telegramm
verschwörungsideologie die sie auf den
Tisch legen mein Gott
aber ich will gern zum Thema reden
[Applaus]
und will sagen viele Kommunen in
Deutschland verbringen gerade wieder ein
enormen Kraftakt und ich bin Ihnen sehr
dankbar dafür den Ehrenamtlichen aber
natürlich auch den hauptamtlichen in den
Behörden in den kommunal bei den
kommunalen Verantwortlichen aber
Dankbarkeit alleine reicht natürlich
nicht einige von ihnen stehen gerade
wieder vor extrem hohen Belastung Schul-
und Kitaplätze fehlen bezahlbare
Wohnungen ja es sind eine Million
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine zu den übrigen
geflüchteten hinzugekommen wir stehen
dazu wir wollen das aber wer klein redet
das ist Schwierigkeiten gibt der hilft
weder den Kommunen noch hilft er den
geflüchteten die Realität anerkennen
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen das heißt
Soforthilfe zu allererst brauchen die
Kommunen genügend Geld um die Strukturen
vor und aufrecht zu erhalten die jetzt
notwendig sind
zweitens
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Verfahren schneller werden dass wir
viele gefürchtete so schnell wie möglich
ihr Status geklärt wird und drittens das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht des wirkt zum
ersten Mal seit vielen Jahren ist die
Zahl der ausreisepflichtigen
zurückgegangen weil diese Menschen in
Arbeit sind weil sie in Arbeit sind
helfen wo überall es geht weil sie in
Arbeit sind und übrigens auch in die
Sozialsysteme einzahlen meine Damen und
Herren die Realität anerkennen
die Realität anerkennen das heißt aber
eben auch endlich langfristig zu denken
und vorbereitet sein und ich weiß und
das schätze ich sehr dass sie von der
Union nach 2015 ausdrücklich gemeinsam
mit uns eingeschätzt haben wir waren
damals auf diese Situation nicht
vorbereitet wir haben nicht anerkannt
dass die krisenhärte längst da waren wir
hätten wissen können dass mehr
geflüchtete kommen sollen wir hätten uns
vorbereiten sollen dieser Fehler von
damals den dürfen den sollten wir nie
wieder machen wir brauchen Vorbereitung
wir brauchen Strategien wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Kommunen und dass die
Strukturen in unserem Land so arbeiten
können dass auch dann wenn mehr Menschen
kommen noch menschenwürdige
Unterbringung da ist aber dass die
Kommune nicht echtzen weil von allem zu
wenig vorhanden ist meine Damen und
Herren diese Planbarkeit
diese Planbarkeit ist der Grund für
alles was wir in Zukunft organisieren
müssen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kolleginnen
gestatten Sie einen Zwischenruf oder
zwischen Bemerkungen Zwischenruf nicht
tschuldigung eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen aus der cdu/cs
der Hoffmann okay
danke Frau Kollegin Göring-Eckardt dass
sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen ist
nämlich eine Frage die ich habe sie
haben gerade
ich sage jetzt mal sehr mütterlich
gesagt wir müssen dafür sorgen dass wir
im Land die Strukturen haben um die
Menschen unterzubringen jetzt gibt es in
meinem Wahlkreis sagen Sie mal lassen
Sie mich doch mal die Frage stellen
warum sind sie denn so Unlocker
dann ist es halt mütterlich und
väterlich gewesen so jetzt gibt's bei
mir im Wahlkreis einen grünen Landrat
Jens Marco Scherf
das ist ihre Partei der hat vor Monaten
schon einen Brief an die
bundesinnenministerin geschrieben vor
Monaten einen Brief an den Bundeskanzler
geschrieben und hat dort wirklich sehr
sachlich und ohne Schaum vor dem Mund
mal die praktischen Probleme vor Ort
geschildert dass wir nämlich keine
Flächen mehr haben um die Menschen
unterzubringen dass wir keine
Kita-Plätze mehr haben dass wir keine
Schulplätze mehr haben alles platzt aus
allen Nähten und das schildert jemand
der ihr Parteibuch und jetzt haben sie
einen sehr allgemeinen Satz gesagt und
ich würde jetzt gerne von Ihnen mal
wissen was sagen Sie dem grünen Landrat
Jens Marco Scherf wie sie diese
Herausforderung die vor Ort besteht
nicht hier in der Berliner Blase und
nicht in diesem Haus sondern vor Ort
wie wir ihm helfen dass er dieses
Problem vor Ort bewältigen kann
[Applaus]
für das
einzugehen was die Realität und was die
tatsächlichen Probleme vor Ort sind und
sie haben ein Scherz angesprochen sie
könnten auch lesen was die
Oberbürgermeister vieler Kommunen gesagt
hat vielleicht haben Sie auch gelesen
was der Gemeinde und Städtetag gesagt
hat die haben mich sehr deutlich gesagt
was wir brauchen sind für diese
Strukturen finanzielle Mittel und ja ich
sage sehr klar und sehr eindeutig diese
finanziellen Mittel müssen zur Verfügung
gestellt werden das zweite was der
Gemeinde und Städtetag gesagt hat
übrigens auch gerade vier
Oberbürgermeisterin Oberbürgermeister
die auch meiner Partei angehören was
notwendig ist ist tatsächlich
Planbarkeit für die Zukunft wir können
nicht so tun und das atmet leider der
Katalog den Sie vorgelegt haben wir
können nicht so tun dass wir mit allen
möglichen Maßnahmen die gut klingen das
Problem tatsächlich lösen würden nein
wir lösen es wenn wir klarmachen wir
sind ein Einwanderungsland wir sind ein
Land von Migration wir sind ein Land in
dem ich hoffe da sind sie dabei das
individuelle Recht auf Asyl gilt wir
sind ein Land in dem man Obergrenzen
festigt aber gerne Richtwerte was wir
worauf wir uns vorbereiten müssen dieses
Land sollten wir sein dieses Land wollen
wir seit unter zugehört vor allen Dingen
und darauf will ich jetzt gleich auch
eingehen dass wir Menschen so schnell
wie möglich in Arbeit bringen und damit
auch in Wohnungen bringen und damit
dafür sorgen dass sie selbstständig
leben können in unserem Land ohne darauf
angewiesen zu sein in erstaufnahmen zu
sein das ist der Schlüssel und wir haben
bereits gezeigt dass es funktioniert mit
dem chancenaufenthaltsrecht darüber
hatte ich ja gerade gesprochen vielen
Dank
natürlich
müssen damit das alles funktioniert auch
die Verfahren beschleunigt werden
natürlich müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
es resettenment gibt dass wir eine
gemeinsame europäische Lösung
hinbekommen anders wird es nicht gehen
darauf sind wir angewiesen und darüber
sollten wir uns auch immer wieder klar
sein wir brauchen faire Migration und
auch Rückführungsabkommen deswegen haben
wir übrigens zum ersten Mal einen
Beauftragten dazu das hatten wir in all
den vergangenen Jahren übrigens nicht
meine Damen und Herren
wir brauchen Ordnung ja aber wir
brauchen eben auch Humanität meine Damen
und Herren wir leben in einem Land
das für seine Werte steht
und das mit seinem Grundgesetz dafür
sorgt dass es Grundrecht auf Asyl
selbstverständlich ist das ist die Lehre
aus unserer Geschichte in doppelter
Weise nämlich nach 1945 aber auch nach
1989 meine Damen und Herren auch diese
Lehre müssen wir ziehen dass Menschen
die Asyl beantragen bei uns einen fairen
ein fairen Prozess bekommen eine faire
Bearbeitung ihrer Anträge bekommen ja
schnell ja ordentlich und bitte
rechtsstaatlich aber tun wir bitte nicht
so als ob wir das anders machen können
nein ich habe daran kein Zweifel darauf
will ich gerne eingehen aber sie haben
ja inzwischen schon in verschiedener
Weise zur Kenntnis gegeben dass sie
eigentlich das individuelle Recht auf
also nicht mehr wollen Herrn und
deswegen sage ich ganz klar das sehen
wir anders wir halten es für ein Gebot
unseres Grundgesetzes und
selbstverständlich des Völkerrechtes das
aufrecht zu erhalten meine Damen und
Herren
und deswegen
es geht in unserem Land um Respekt es
geht in unserem Land um Zusammenhalt und
Zusammenleben und Sie können doch nicht
erklären was ist mit dem 200.000 und
ersten und auch deswegen kann es keine
Obergrenze gehen sie können doch auch
nicht erklären wie soll sich jemand hier
eigentlich integrieren den wir sagen
nein deine Familie kann nicht nachgeholt
werden das ist ein massives
integrationshemmnis und deswegen sage
ich nein das wird nicht funktionieren
und schließlich und zum Schluss
jedes Jahr in den nächsten 30 Jahren
brauchen wir
400.000 Menschen die bei uns arbeiten
und deswegen brauchen wir auch Antworten
die wirtschaftlich vernünftig sind und
es gibt in diesem Land unzählige
Unternehmen jedes zweite sagt uns wir
sind froh wenn wir geflüchtete
einstellen können da geht es nicht um
die imaginäre Fachkraft die wir
vielleicht nach Deutschland holen können
es geht darum diejenigen die längst hier
sind die als geflüchtete gekommen sind
einzustellen in der Bäckerei im Hotel
bei der Gastro heute Nacht wurde über
lkw-fahrerinnen ja genau darum geht es
und es sind nicht zwei getrennte Themen
wir können nicht auf der einen Seite
anwerben wollen und auf der anderen
Seite abgrenzen das funktioniert nicht
das gehört zusammen wer möchte dass
Menschen nach Deutschland kommen um hier
zu arbeiten denen muss man auch klar
sagen ja wir sind ein Land das da für
offen ist wir brauchen Ordnung
wir brauchen einen Blick auf die Chancen
meine Damen und Herren aber wir sollten
nicht vergessen dass das zentrale wenn
es um Menschen in Not geht die
Menschlichkeit ist herzlichen Dank
katrin
Göring-Eckardt aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen hat noch mal betont welche
Bedeutung das Asylrecht für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat und das dürfte
endlich auch gelten für Clara Bünger aus
der Linksfraktion die dort
fluchtpolitische Sprecherin ist
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Gäste auf
den Tribünen es ist doch erstaunlich die
Union wird der Ampel vor keine neuen
migrationspolitischen Ansätze vorzulegen
und keine substanziellen Lösungen
anbieten zu können und dann präsentiert
sie uns einen Antrag mit einem
Forderungskatalog auf den genau diese
Kritik zutrifft nämlich keine
substanziellen Lösung stattdessen
stattdessen setzen sie nur auf
Abschottung und Entrechtung und ich
möchte Ihnen das an drei Beispielen aus
ihrem Antrag mal deutlich machen erstes
Beispiel die CDU will frontext stärken
sie wollen das frontext unerlaubte
einreisen stoppt meine Damen und Herren
frontext ist die EU-Agentur die unter
anderem darin verwickelt ist Menschen
die auf kleinen boten auf offenen Meer
im Mittelmeer ankommen zurück zu drängen
ja das ist nicht nicht nur unmenschlich
sondern dass es auch schlicht
rechtswidrig hat der Einsatz von Frontex
denn jemals bisher dazu geführt dass
weniger geflüchtete kommen nein die CDU
will zweitens polfaktoren also
vermeintliche Anreize für geflüchtete
vermeiden Sozialstandards absenken ich
habe das hier schon sehr häufig gesagt
und ich sage es auch wieder es gibt
immer noch keine wissenschaftlichen
Belege dafür dass Anreize der Grund sind
dass Menschen sich auf den gefährlichen
und häufig tödlichen Weg der Flucht
machen ich er sag ihnen mal was Menschen
fliehen weil Kriege und repressive
Regime sie dazu zwingen und ihnen keine
Wahl lassen nicht weil es in Deutschland
so tolle Sozialleistungen gibt
hören Sie endlich auf diesen
gefährlichen Unsinn zu erzählen
die CDU will drittens noch schärfere
Regeln bei Abschiebung der letzte
Innenminister der Union Horst Seehofer
hat das Aufenthaltsrecht bereits massiv
verschärft um noch mehr Abschiebungen
durchführen zu kennen Verschärfung in
rechten nur noch mehr Menschen mit
prekären Aufenthaltsstatus sie führen in
der Praxis aber nicht dazu dass es mehr
Abschiebungen geben wird
nämlich
das wird auch nicht dazu führen dass
weniger geflüchtete nach Deutschland
kommen
und interessant ist
interessant ist übrigens darüber haben
wir gestern gesprochen über Obergrenzen
und heute war das auch schon mal wieder
Thema dass sie die Forderungen nach
einer Obergrenze für Asylsuchende nicht
in den Antrag reingeschrieben haben im
Grunde wissen sie nämlich ganz genau
dass das individuelle Asylrecht nicht
kontingentierbar ist und eine Obergrenze
mit EU und Völkerrecht nicht vereinbar
wäre das hindert aber Söder und März
nicht daran lautstark mit diesem Thema
auf dem Rücken von geflüchteten auf
Marktplätzen Wahlkampf zu machen denken
sie eigentlich darüber nach das ist bei
den Menschen über die sie da sprechen um
Kinder Frauen und Männer geht die
schrecklich des erlebt haben die dem Tod
vor Augen gesehen haben ich frage mich
wo ist ihr Gewissen an dieser Stelle
keiner der diesen keine in diesem Hause
der Menschenrechte anerkennt und
Menschenrechte basierte Politik machen
möchte kann diesen Vorschlag von ihm
zustimmen wir werden diesen Vorschlag
nicht zustimmen aber eine wichtige Sache
möchte ich sagen niemand hier leugnet
das Kommunen Hilfe brauchen es ist aber
eine Frage des politischen Willens ob
man diese Hilfe leistet und es ist kein
Automatismus dass die Ankunft von
Schutzsuchenden zu Chaos führt um das zu
vermeiden brauchen wir brauchen die
Kommunen die nötige Unterstützung sie
brauchen Geld und sie brauchen
bezahlbare Wohnungen Schulen und
Kitaplätze das würde allen Menschen in
Deutschland helfen und davon hören wir
von ihnen von der CDU gar nichts und der
AFD sowieso nicht und von der Ampel
leider auch nicht weil sie sich dem Spar
Diktat von Linda Lindner unterworfen hat
aus unserer Sicht sollten Sie endlich
soziale Politik für alle Menschen in
diesem Land machen vielen Dank
klarer Bünger war das fluchtpolitische
Sprecherin der Fraktion DIE LINKE hier
im Deutschen Bundestag der über einen
Antrag der Unionsfraktion zur
Migrationspolitik diskutiert dazu jetzt
Konstantin Kohle stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der FDP-Fraktion Damen und
Herren seit dem Ausbruch des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine sind
über eine Million ukrainischer
Vertriebener nach Deutschland gekommen
im vergangenen Jahr haben zusätzlich
etwa eine viertel Millionen Menschen
einen Antrag auf Asyl in Deutschland
gestellt in diesem Jahr werden es
voraussichtlich 300.000 Menschen sein
all diese Menschen müssen vernünftig
versorgt werden all diese Menschen
müssen untergebracht werden all diese
Menschen durchlaufen ein
rechtsstaatliches Verfahren und die
Hauptlast dieser Situation tragen die
Kommunen tragen die Städte und Gemeinden
und ich glaube wir müssen uns auch noch
mal klar machen dass dieser gigantische
Akt der europäischen Solidarität
gegenüber der Ukraine ohne das
Engagement der Kommunen nie mals möglich
gewesen wäre liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
jetzt aber sind wir in einer Situation
angelangt in der die Städte und
Gemeinden nicht mehr können die Zahlen
sind zu hoch die Kommunen ächzen die
Städte und Gemeinden wissen nicht weiter
und sie erwarten von uns eine wirksame
Begrenzung der irregulären Migration und
das muss dieser Bundestag das muss auch
diese Bundesregierung leisten liebe
Kolleginnen und ich glaube dass ein
großer Teil
der Frustration ein großer Teil der
Enttäuschung die der momentan in der
Gesellschaft sehen daran liegt dass hier
Reden gehalten werden über die
Begrenzung der irregulären Migration
aber in dem Kommunen nichts davon
bemerkt wird und mit jeder Rede in der
beschworen wird dass eine Begrenzung der
irregulären Migration stattfinden soll
aber dann in den Kommunen nichts ankommt
wächst diese Frustration wächst diese
Enttäuschung weiter und ich kann es
verstehen liebe Kolleginnen dazu
gerne einige konkrete Beispiele erstes
Beispiel die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat im Mai
beschlossen im Mai dieses Jahres das
Georgien und molder als sichere
Herkunftsstaaten eingestuft werden
sollen jetzt haben wir september und die
Einstufung hat immer noch nicht
stattgefunden dafür habe ich kein
Verständnis liebe Kolleginnen
zweites Beispiel
die Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat
parteiübergreifend ein bundesgremium
diese Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
beschlossen dass um Abschiebungen zu
erleichtern der ausreisegewahrsam
verlängert werden soll auf 28 Tage das
war im Mai jetzt ist September es ist
immer noch nicht beschlossen worden
dafür habe ich kein Verständnis liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ein drittes Beispiel
[Applaus]
wir müssen damit aufhören uns beim Thema
Abschiebungen als Bund und Länder
ständig gegenseitig auf den Füßen zu
stehen natürlich müssen wir als Bund
unsere Hausaufgaben machen um im
internationalen Bereich die
Voraussetzungen verabschiebungen zu
schaffen Joachim stammt der
sonderbevollmächtigte der
Bundesregierung ist heute morgen aus
Nairobi wiedergekommen ist im Osteuropa
unterwegs er ist in Afrika unterwegs er
ist in Asien unterwegs und verhandelt
migrations- und Rückübernahme Abkommen
aber die Länder müssen die Abschiebung
dann auch durchführen und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
natürlich kann Joachim stammt nicht in
einem Jahr aufholen was Horst Seehofer
in vier Jahren nicht gemacht hat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
so und wenn ich mir dann den Antrag der
Union anschaue in dem Teil wir fordern
die Bundesregierung auf dann frage ich
mich mit unter ob sie uns eigentlich
verschaukeln wollen da steht drin
Sachleistungen durch sollen durchgeführt
werden wir halten es als Freie
Demokraten für richtig verstärkt auf
Bezahlkarten und auch Sachleistungen zu
setzen weil das die Anreize für
irreguläre Migration sinkt aber wissen
Sie was Sachleistungen stehen doch
längst im Gesetz ich habe heute morgen
noch mal nachgezählt acht von 16
Innenministern in Deutschland werden von
der CDU und der CSU gestellt warum
fordern Sie uns denn auf etwas zu etwas
auf wofür sie zuständig sind machen Sie
es doch einfach in den Ländern setzen
darauf Sachen Leistung auf Bezahlkarte
ist doch alles längst beschlossen warum
geht es nicht los so und ein letztes
Beispiel will ich nennen das ist das
Thema Europa wir haben im nächsten Jahr
Europawahl und ich finde dass die
Möglichkeit der Innenministerin und
Innenminister auf europäischer Ebene
eine gemeinsame Haltung in der Asyl und
Flüchtlingspolitik zu finden ein großer
Schritt in die richtige Richtung war das
ist eine wichtige Leistung und ich
bedanke mich dafür dass das möglich
gewesen ist
allerdings ist es so dass diese
Verhandlungen momentan Stocken und wir
dürfen es nicht riskieren dass
Deutschland der Bremser bei der
Neufassung eines gemeinsamen
europäischen Asylsystems ist wir müssen
das vor der Europawahl zum Abschluss
bringen wir müssen das beschließen und
wir müssen dazu beitragen dass es in der
Europäischen Union das ist auf diesem
Kontinent eine gemeinsame Asylpolitik
gibt damit wir die Binnengrenzen offen
halten können und gemeinsam die
Außengrenzen schützen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Bundeskanzler der
Bundeskanzler hat vorgeschlagen einen
Deutschland packt in Sachen Migration er
hat ihnen die Hand ausgestreckt sie
haben diese Hand heute weggeschlagen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union haben mit einem Tonfall eine
Schärfe in diese Debatte gebracht die
völlig unangebracht und unangemessen ist
ich wünsche mir dass wir mit
Selbstkritik dass wir mit Reflexion dass
wir auch mit Kompromissbereitschaft
gemeinsam dieses Thema lösen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber da ist der
heutige Antrag leider kein Beitrag
lassen Sie uns die von mir genannten
Punkte auf den Weg bringen und lassen
sie uns daran
arbeiten dass dieses Thema nicht von
denjenigen weiter ausgeschlachtet wird
die nichts Gutes im Schilde führen
herzlichen Dank
Konstantin Kohle mit dem wunschmann möge
vielleicht doch noch konstruktiv
zusammenarbeiten das wird schwierig in
Wahlkampf Zeiten aber er Kritik am
unionsantrag geübte lässt aber auch die
unter unterschiedlichen Vorstellungen in
der Ampel nicht unerwähnt und der
nächste Redner wieder aus der
Unionsfraktion Thorsten frei erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das was wir
hier in dieser Debatte erleben ist die
vollendete
Realitätsverweigerung machen Sie sich
doch mal mit dem Begebenheiten vertraut
wir sehen doch jeden Tag wie Menschen an
den Küsten Italiens und Lampedusas
anlanden und die bleiben dort nicht die
ziehen nach Norden die Behörden die
Regierungen in Rom ist weder im Stande
noch ist sie will ins Asylanträge dort
zu bearbeiten und die Folge ist das bis
zum 31 August diesen Jahres mehr als
220.000 Asylanträge in Deutschland
gestellt worden sind und wenn ich diesen
Trend extra poliere dann bedeutet es in
den nächsten Monaten dass wir bis zum
Jahresende zwischen 350 und 400.000
Asylanträge in Deutschland haben werden
und es grenzt doch an
Realitätsverweigerung wenn Sie hier den
Eindruck erwecken Frau Göring-Eckardt
als wäre das alles eine Frage des Geldes
es ist nicht in erster Linie eine Frage
des Geldes soll seine Frage der Tatsache
dass die Infrastruktur in Deutschland in
ihrer Breite auf eine auf Zuzug in
dieser Größenordnung nicht vorbereitet
ist das ist die Realität
hören Sie Ihren eigenen
Kommunalpolitikern zu wir haben sie am
30 März hierher in den Bundestag
eingeladen 400 Bürgermeister und
Landräte aller Parteien aus dem ganzen
Land und die haben uns eindrucksvoll
gezeigt woran es mangelt es mangelt an
Wohnraum an Kitaplätzen an Schulen in
der medizinischen Versorgung das sind
ihre Themen die sie nicht bearbeitet
bekommen und es lösen sie nicht
kurzfristig mit mehr Geld sondern das
lösen sie mit Ordnung Steuerung und
Begrenzung von Migration sie waren aber
diejenigen die in diesem Sommer das Wort
Begrenzung aus dem Paragraphen eins des
Aufenthaltsgesetzes gestrichen haben sie
wollen keine Lösung erlauben sie die
Zwischenfrage
sind uns ja einig und ich habe das hier
ausführlich gesagt dass die Strukturen
nicht ausreichend sind und ich habe
gerade darauf verwiesen dass wir sofort
Hilfe brauchen nämlich mit mehr Geld
damit Strukturen aufgebaut werden können
und dass wir vorbereitet sein müssen
dafür dass auch in Zukunft Menschen zu
uns kommen werden die diese Strukturen
benötigen ich frage sie allerdings was
glauben Sie eigentlich warum wir diese
Strukturen nicht haben was haben Sie
Herr frei und die Union insgesamt und
die Innenminister der Union und die
Bauminister zum Beispiel Horst Seehofer
aus der Situation nach 2015 gelernt
haben Sie denn gelernt dass man
vielleicht nicht Größen einführt um die
Strukturen vorzubereiten haben Sie
vielleicht gelernt das ist mehr Kita und
Schulplätze braucht haben Sie vielleicht
gelernt dass es mehr sozialen
Wohnungsbau braucht der übrigens dann
auch allen hilft ich habe den Eindruck
sie haben es nicht gelernt sie sagen
jetzt haltet den Dieb bei den warum
müssen die sie selbst angerichtet haben
und darauf können wir heute nur eine
Antwort geben wir werden weiter an den
Strukturen arbeiten ja wir werden auch
Rückführungen durchführen ich habe das
erwähnt daran führt gar kein Weg vorbei
wir werden registrieren während nach
Europa kommt ja selbstverständlich was
denn sonst aber sie können nicht so tun
als ob die fehlenden Strukturen die das
Ergebnis der letzten zwei Jahre sind sie
müssen sich wenn wir das gemeinsam
hinbekommen wollen und da plädiere ich
wirklich an ihr Verständnis von
Demokratie und von Zusammenhalt in
unserer Gesellschaft dann müssen sie
sich an die eigene Nase fassen wir
müssen gemeinsam Lösungen finden
Strukturen aufbauen muss das auf jeden
Fall heißen und Ordnung
selbstverständlich auch aber beides
gehört zusammen Ordnung und Humanität
verehrte Frau Göring-Eckardt ja Ordnung
und Humanität gehört zusammen das stimmt
aber ansonsten scheinen sie nichts
verstanden zu haben
werfen Sie mal einen Blick in den
Bundeshaushalt da steht drin dass wir in
die letzten Jahren ja für ja etwa 25
Milliarden Euro für das Thema Migration
aufgewendet haben es gibt kein zweites
Land auf der Erde das so viel zur
Bekämpfung der Migration zur Ordnung der
Migration zur Aufnahme von
schutzbedürftigen ausgibt zur Bekämpfung
von Fluchtursachen wie Deutschland und
ich will es ihnen ganz klar sagen nein
ich bestreite die Versäumnisse die Sie
ansprechen ich bin der Auffassung dass
wir nicht jährlich zwischen 400.000 und
700.000 Menschen im Wege der humanitären
Migration in Deutschland aufnehmen
können und deswegen kann man dafür weder
Strukturen schaffen noch wäre das
wünschenswert beschäftigen sie sich mit
der Realität es geht nicht darum dass
wir uns nur mit diesem einen Thema
beschäftigen sondern es geht darum dass
wir auch für die Aufnahmegesellschaft in
Deutschland und die
aufnahmegesellschaften in Europa
Verhältnisse schaffen wo Integration
möglich ist und nicht das Ausbilden von
Parallelgesellschaften das wäre die
Folge ihrer Politik und das lehnen wir
ab und deswegen wird es auf der Basis
ihrer Vorschläge mit Sicherheit keine
Verständigung mit uns geben können meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung tut exakt des Gegenteil
von dem was notwendig wäre die
Innenministerin hat die Schuppe hier
hinzustehen und zu sagen sie hätte einen
klaren Kurs in der Migrationspolitik ja
sie hat einen klaren Kurs aber in die
falsche Richtung verehrte Frau Facer was
haben Sie denn gemacht in ihrer
Regierungszeit sie haben Bleiberecht für
abgelehnte Asylbewerber sie führen nicht
zurück die Zahlen sind so niedrig wie
nie zuvor sie ermöglichen den
Spurwechsel in zwei Jahren haben sie die
Sozialleistungen um 25% erhöht sie
machen immer das Gegenteil von dem was
notwendig ist und jetzt spekulieren sie
noch darum dass sie zwar nicht jetzt
aber in Zukunft den Familiennachzug
erleichtern möchten das ist doch das
Gegenteil von dem was notwendig und
richtig wäre liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und dann feiern Sie sich dafür dass sie
die erste und einzige Innenministerin
wären die jemals auf europäischer Ebene
an einer Verbesserung der Verhältnisse
mitgewirkt hätte ich will ihnen sagen es
ist ein magerer Kompromiss auf
europäischer Ebene gewesen der noch
lange nicht europäisches Recht ist
dieser Kompromiss wäre viel besser
gewesen wenn sie nicht beteiligt gewesen
wären Frau Facer sie sind der Grund
dafür warum es keine bessere
Verständigung auf europäischer Ebene
gegeben hat und jetzt tun sie alles
dafür dass dieser Kompromiss auch noch
hintertrieben wird das ist das Gegenteil
von dem was notwendig ist und deswegen
haben wir mal sehr klar aufgeschrieben
was man jetzt sehr schnell und sehr
unmittelbar tun müsste jetzt müsste man
tatsächlich mehr sichere
Herkunftsstaaten schaffen man müsste
mehr Sachleistungen weniger
Geldleistungen haben man müsste dafür
sorgen dass wir den Grenzschutz in
Deutschland und in Europa
gewährleisten können es gibt so viele
Möglichkeiten die Sie tun können aber
Sie können es nicht Frau Innenministerin
und weil sie überfordert sind stelle ich
mir die Frage nicht nur heute morgen wo
ist eigentlich der Herr Bundeskanzler
das frage ich mich wirklich in einer
Krise wie wir sie jetzt haben müsste der
Bundeskanzler sich doch an die Spitze
der Bewegung Stellen zusammen mit
Emanuel macron zusammen mit Ursula von
der Leyen aber er hat hier im Deutschen
Bundestag keine einzige Rede gehalten wo
er sich intensiv mit dem Thema
auseinandergesetzt hätte es gibt keine
einzige internationale Verhandlung die
er geführt hätte es gibt kein einzigen
politischen Vorstoß des Bundeskanzlers
der Bundeskanzler ist Schlafwandler und
der delegiert diese wichtige
Herausforderung an eine Ministerin die
es ganz offensichtlich nicht kann und
mit dem Kopf eher in Wiesbaden als in
Berlin ist herzlichen Dank
Thorsten Frey erster parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion und
wenn man hier dieser Debatte so seit
ungefähr 20 nach zehn folgt dann hat man
nicht den Eindruck dass hier Union und
Ampel in irgendeiner Weise noch
zusammenkommen können bei diesem Thema
und das könnte ich sag's mit aller
Vorsicht durchaus im Moment auch mit den
Wahlkämpfen in Hessen und in Bayern zu
tun haben wie gesagt ich sag's in aller
Vorsicht Sebastian hartmann ist in
politischer Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
und ampult
die Lautstärke der Union kann nicht
darüber hinweg täuschen dass die Union
entweder eine Abrechnung mit sich selbst
vornimmt und wenn man in den Antrag
schaut auf der anderen Seite auch keine
eigenen Vorschläge deswegen will ich für
alle Mitbürgerinnen und mitbürgerchen
aller Klarheit sagen weder das was Herrn
Söder wohl offensichtlich nach dem Fass
Anstich auf dem Oktoberfest eingefallen
ist nämlich eine
integrationsobergrenze alias Seehofers
Obergrenze einzuführen findet sich in
diesem Antrag noch Herr hochverehrter
Kollege frei ihre Spekulation um die
Einführung eines Kontingents und
Abschaffung des individualrechtes auf
Asyl offensichtlich kann sich weder
Alexander Dobrindt noch Markus Söder
noch sehr frei in ihrer Fraktion
durchsetzen denn nichts von dem was sie
durch die Kassetten treiben durch die
Wirtshäuser schreien findet sich in
diesem Antrag sie streuen in deutschen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern Sand in die
Augen
der zweite Punkt
und da müssen sie eigentlich den Boden
versinken dass der einzige Applaus in
diesem Haus nicht eine ausgestreckte
Hand ist sondern das grünende
klatschende AFD auf der rechten Seite
merken sie nicht dass sie auf dem
falschen Pfad sind kehren sie um
während sie um sie zerstören die debat
indem sie auch den deutschen darüber
täuschen liebe Mitbürger und Mitbürger
Liebe ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer sie
werden darüber getäuscht dass die Ampel
im dezember 2021 ein Scherbenhaufen auf
europäischer Ebene vorgefunden hat eines
gescheiterten europäischen Asylsystems
als direkte Konsequenz von Angela
Merkels Alleingang der schaffen das
gegen Europa und dann auch es nicht
geschafft hat mit Horst Seehofer
überhaupt eine einzige europäische
Einigung hinzubekommen das Ergebnis von
16 Jahren unionsgeführter Innenpolitik
waren 300 5000 vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtiger Menschen die nicht
zurückgeführt werden können was kann ein
einziges migrationsabkommen gab und es
ist ein grobes Täuschungsmanöver zu
behaupten sichere Herkunftsstaaten wären
die Lösung ist eine einfache
Verfahrensvereinfachung sie werfen mit
Nebelkerzen täuschen über das eigene
Versagen hinweg und das ist ist das
Ergebnis ihres Versuches mit Angela
Merkel abzurechn
en und wenn sie so weitermachen dann
werden Sie sehen dass in Bayern ihr
Franz-Josef Strauß sagt es darf keine
Partei rechts von der CSU gibt jetzt
haben wir eine freie Wählerschaft und
eine AFD in gleicher stärker einer CSU
die vor den schlechtesten
Umfrageergebnissen und Wahlen steht die
Sie jemals hatte in Bayern und deswegen
deswegen versuchen Sie diese Debatte zu
instrumentalisieren es gab keinen
Versuch der Zusammenarbeit es gab keinen
versuchter Zusammenarbeit es gab keine
ausgestreckte Hand und es ist die
deutsche Innenministerin Nancy Faeser
gewesen sie das erste Mal geschafft hat
auf europäischer Ebene dass wir die
krisenverordnung hinbekommen und ich
sage Ihnen meine Damen und Herren wir
werden vor der Europawahl eine Einigung
auf europäischer Ebene haben wir werden
auch die krisenverordnung durchsetzen
Deutschland wird führend sein wenn es um
den Neustart des europäischen Asylsystem
gibt und niemand bestreitet dass wir die
reguläre Migration zurückdrängen müssen
denn das darf nicht damit ein Geschäft
geben aber wir müssen sauber trennen
zwischen denen die einen Asyl Anspruch
haben und ein fluchtanspruch haben und
das auch nachweisen aber sie werden
nicht alle in Deutschland untergebracht
werden sondern Sie sind auf Europa zu
verteilen und nicht nur nach Deutschland
zu kommen und auch das ist ein Bruch mit
Merkels Migrationspolitik und das
schaffen wir auf europäischer Ebene und
auch hier streuen Sie den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern sind die Augen meine Damen
und Herren
können Sie auf die Debatte zu
missbrauchen hören Sie auf die Tonlage
zu vergiften und man merkt wie stilles
in den Reihen der Union war weil das was
ich aufgezählt habe waren alles Fakten
es ist alles in Text nachzulesen es ist
alles dokumentiert und ihr lautes
gescheit euch darüber hinweg dass sie
gar nichts im Angebot haben außer
stillen Tönen das Ergebnis wird die
Stärkung der rechten Seite im Planung im
Plenum sein aber kein besseres
Wahlergebnis wenn Sie ernsthaft mit uns
zusammenarbeiten wollen wenn Sie
ernsthaft mit uns zusammen arbeiten
wollen an einem nationalen Kraftwerk für
einen Neustart im europäischen
Asylsystem der Steuerung der
Migrationspolitik und endlich Ebenen
übergreifend Kommunen Länder und Bund an
den Tisch so und dann ist unsere Hand
ausgestreckt aber ändern Sie bitte den
Ton
Sebastian Hartmann der in politische
Sprecher der SPD Fraktion heute morgen
auch in Interview bei uns genauso wie
der übernächste Redner Alexander drum
der noch kommt jetzt erstmal vieles
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
migrationsexpertin ihrer Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren nach der gestrigen und
heutigen Debatte zum selben Thema ist
mir einmal mehr klar geworden wir haben
tatsächlich unterschiedliche Analysen
der Lagen und kommen da zu anderen
Schlussfolgerungen
um den immensen Herausforderungen
gerecht zu werden gerade in Zeiten von
Kriegen und Krisen wir sind tatsächlich
der Überzeugung dass ihre Politik der
Abschottung oder Begrenzung zu mehr
Chaos und Leid führt und infolgedessen
rechtsextreme und rechte Regierung
Auftrieb erhalten
beispielhaft und das ist auch von der
Union schon genannt worden möchte ich
eben Italien nennen wo nun die
postfaschistinnen diese Politik auf die
Spitze treiben jene Postfaschisten den
ihre schwesterparteivorsa Italia den Weg
an die Macht bereitet hat meine Damen
und Herren wir sind außer dem der
Überzeugung dass es ihnen an Respekt und
Redlichkeit gegenüber geflüchteten
Menschen fehlt
das diskreditiert wird wo Empathie
gezeigt werden sollte
Schutzsuchenden wird permanent und zum
wiederholten Male auch in ihren Anträgen
Herr frei pauschal in Abrede gestellt
dass sie aus Gründen von Krieg und
Verfolgung kommen und ich wünschte dass
die Zuschauer in den Antrag einmal
reingucken könnten in Ihrem Antrag wird
mit keinem Wort erwähnt dass über 70
Prozent aller geflüchteten aus kriegs-
Afghanistan Iran
Somalia Eritrea verfolgte aus der Türkei
und jesidenen aus dem Irak
entsprechend hoch meine Damen und Herren
ist die schutzquote in Deutschland
findet keine Erwähnung in ihrem Antrag
warum eigentlich nicht
und ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch was
betonen die Zahl derjenigen Menschen die
sich irregulär Frau Ministerin in
Deutschland aufhalten sie haben es
korrigiert
gegenüber der CDU beläuft sich derzeit
auch rund 56.000 Menschen das ist der
Stand 22 Dezember hierbei handelt es
sich um dokumentierte ausreisepflichtige
Personen also abgelehnte
AsylbewerberInnen aber auch ausländische
Studierende Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Touristinnen deren Visum abgelaufen ist
und meine Damen und Herren diese Zahl
der irregulären Migranten ist nicht zu
verwechseln wie die Union das ständig
tut mit der Zahl der unerlaubt
eingereisten Personen ganz wichtig dass
wir die Fakten auseinanderhalten denn
alle Personen
die ohne gültiges Visum oder
Aufenthaltstitel nach Deutschland
einreisen in der Regel im übrigen
geflüchtete weil sie kein Visum stellen
können in kriegsländern gelten zunächst
als unerlaubt eingereist meine Damen und
Herren sobald aber eine Person in
Deutschland ein Asylantrag stellt sind
diese Person eben nicht mehr unerlaubt
eingereist die Verfahren werden
eingestellt sie bekommen eine
Aufenthaltsgestattung und sind somit
legal in Deutschland und diese Zahl wird
leider nie erwähnt Liebe Union warum
eigentlich nicht keine Zwischenfragen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
sie die denn zulassen keine
Zwischenfragen
Herr Hoffmann hat mich in seinen
Wahlkreis eingeladen und bisher noch
nicht eingelöst damit wir mal
debattieren können ich möchte gerne im
Zusammenhang ausführen
eine abschottungsstrategie ist eben
keine Lösung wir sehen uns in Italien
wir sehen uns in Griechenland sie nimmt
lebensbedrohliche Situation von Menschen
billigend in Kauf und die Diffamierung
und Stigmatisierung von
schutzbedürftigen die Kriminalisierung
hat mit Humanität nichts zu tun das ist
tatsächlich unverantwortliche Politik
Politik die in Zeiten wie diesen spaltet
wo sie integrieren sollte meine Damen
und Herren
diese Kollektion setzt sich da ist halt
für Steuerung ein ein Beispiel ist dafür
sichere Fluchtrouten sichere
Fluchtrouten zu schaffen und deshalb
setzen wir auf humanitäre
Aufnahmeprogramme auch national und
eines der erfolgreichsten war ein
Programm unter ihrer Regierung meine
Damen und Herren davon profitieren
nämlich vor allem schutzbedürftige wer
den Zugang zu
integrationssprachkursen wer den Zugang
zu Integration Sprachkursen von Anfang
an bekommt kann unsere Sprache doch
schneller lernen wer keinem
Arbeitsverbot unterliegt kann sein Leben
selbstbestimmt gestalten und unserer
Gesellschaft was zurückgeben warum
finden wir davon nichts in ihrem Antrag
meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren in dieser Debatte
fehlt es an einem gesamtstaatlichen
Bekenntnis dass für alle geflüchteten
gleichermaßen gilt ich möchte noch sagen
die Kirchen die Wohlfahrtsverbände die
NGOs die Gewerkschaften alle die an der
Integration mitwirken sind alle gegen
ihre Maßnahmen sie sind für eine
integrationsoffensive die den
Lebensrealitäten gerecht wird von denen
wir alle profitieren Investitionen in
Kitas in den Wohnungsmarkt wovon wir
alle profitieren und das sollte die
Antwort sein und deshalb freue ich mich
auf die Beratung im Ausschuss herzlichen
Dank
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin und
wiegt eingangsserie das schon sagte auch
die migrationsexpertin ihrer Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und jetzt wie auch
schon angedeutet Alexander throm der
innenpolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion heute morgen bei uns im
Interview mit Sebastian Hartmann
zusammen
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen Kollegen ich war wirklich
gespannt wie die Debatte heute hier
läuft aber die Hoffnung war nicht sehr
groß deswegen kann ich auch nicht
wirklich enttäuscht werden weil alle aus
der Ampel haben sich hinter ihrem
bisherigen Positionen vorbei wir sind
bereit eine Deutschland einzugehen aber
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der kann
doch nicht zu ihren Bedingungen zu ihrer
bisherigen Politik Erfolgen der muss
doch neue Maßnahmen enthalten die
tatsächlich zu einer
begrenzungssteuerung und Ordnung führen
und das habe ich weder beim Kollegen
Hartmann noch Herr Kollege bei ihnen
gesehen wo sie gesagt haben wir hätten
heute ihre Hand wir hätten heute ihre
Hand ausgeschlagen nein umgekehrt ist es
wenn sie nicht auf uns zugehen kann es
einen solchen Deutschland packt nicht
geben und da ist meine Aufforderung
lösen Sie sich hier von dem Gängelband
der Grünen die Frau Polat hat gerade
bewiesen dort ist keinerlei einzigartig
wir brauchen eine asylwende Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und Frau Feser
wie hilflos ist es eigentlich
wenn die SPD und eine amtierende
Innenministerin immer meint auf die
Vorgängerregierung verweisen zu müssen
nur zur Erinnerung sie waren dabei sie
leiden offensichtlich an einer groko
Demenz sie waren es nämlich die uns die
ganzen vier Jahre und davor gehindert
haben mehr Steuerung Begrenzung
durchzuführen viele Maßnahmen auch der
Ausreise Gewahrsam mit 28 Tagen hätten
sie schon vor vier Jahren haben können
nur ihre Justizministerin hat verhindert
und jetzt zu dem Thema Obergrenze diese
Obergrenze ist eine Richtschnur und die
haben wir Herr Kollege Hartmann
gemeinsam in den letzten
Koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt 180
bis 220.000 und wissen Sie was war sie
hat gewirkt wir waren jedes Jahr unter
200.000 erst erzielanträge und deshalb
weil wir damals ein Maßnahmenpaket
geschnürt haben dass die irreguläre
Migration verhindert bzw begrenzt hat
das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem was
sie machen sie haben in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag einen
Paradigmenwechsel hineingeschrieben und
das Ergebnis sehen wir Chaos
Überforderung der Kommunen
Kontrollverlust das ist ihr
Paradigmenwechsel mit einer Vielzahl von
Maßnahmen wo sie alle Schrauben und
Hebel immer auf öffnen und mehr
Migrationen gestellt haben und so können
wir eine deutschlandfahrt nicht machen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Kommunen sind überlastet die
Infrastruktur für so viele Menschen die
zu uns kommen fehlt die Sozialsysteme
sind darauf nicht ausgerichtet und schon
gar nicht auf Dauer und die Menschen in
Deutschland wollen das nicht es ist das
Politik Thema Nummer eins in den Straßen
und Wohnungen in den Kneipen von
Deutschland und das müssen sie endlich
einmal erkennen weil die Akzeptanz für
die Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen und Frau
Kollegen Gühring Eckert diejenige die
wirklich in Not sind und vertrieben und
verfolgt sind denen geben wir natürlich
Hilfe
aber dafür brauchen wir eine Akzeptanz
in unserer Bevölkerung und die war noch
nie so niedrig wie unter ihrer Regierung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich möchte auch auf das Thema
Grenzkontrollen zu sprechen kommen jetzt
immer heißt das funktioniert nicht in
der regierungsbefragung Frau Ministerin
zu Österreich haben sie es verlängert
richtigerweise Polen Tschechien wo die
Grenzübertritte die illegalen deutlich
höher sind als zu Österreich oder von
Österreich haben sie es nicht gemacht
und ich will verweisen auf eine Anfrage
liebe Kollegin Bünger herzlichen Dank
dafür der Linken die im September von
ihnen beantwortet wurde an der Grenze zu
Österreich lag der Anteil der
Zurückweisungen von illegalen
Einwanderern bei 62 Prozent
an der Grenze zu Polen 1,2 und an der
Grenze zu Tschechien
0,07 Prozent Frau Ministerin sie handeln
wieder besseren Wissens sie wüssten das
Grenzkontrollen stationäre bessere
Ergebnisse liefern und illegale
Einwanderung Grenzübertritte verhindert
sie tun es nur nicht weil sie es nicht
machen können mit diesem Grünen und auch
mit ihrer SPD handeln Sie Frau
Ministerin
erlauben sie noch eine Zwischenfrage aus
der Fraktion wie grün aber immer gerne
nee das war der Herr dahinter
Entschuldigung der hatte sich zuerst
gemeldet
also ich gestartet beide auch
nacheinander können Sie mir noch mal
kurz ihren Namen Emmerich danke schön
guten Tag
vielen Dank für das Zulassen der Frage
Kollege throm sie haben gerade die
Zurückweisung angesprochen vorhin hat er
auch die Ministerin schon was dazu noch
mal gesagt ich habe aber noch mal eine
Frage was bedeutet denn die
Zurückweisung in der Konsequenz ist denn
dadurch verhindert dass jemand noch mal
kommen könnte und noch mal eine Grenze
kommen könnte und noch mal in die Grenze
kommen könnte ist es dadurch verhindert
und wie ist es verhält sich das wie
verhält sich das wenn jemand eine Grenze
ist und asylbeantragt kann die Person
dann zurückgewiesen werden da hätte ich
gerne noch mal ein versetzt von ihnen
dazu
ja lieber Kollege Emmerich herzlichen
Dank nein natürlich kann jeder das immer
wieder versuchen deswegen wissen wir
nachhaltig dafür sorgen dass dieses
nicht passiert und dass diese illegalen
Grenzübertritte nicht stattfinden es
gibt keine generalösung aber es gibt es
das hat auch nie jemanden behauptet das
hat das hat nie jemand behauptet aber es
gibt die Möglichkeit des ausnutzen
unseres offenen liberales Systems so gut
wie möglich zu verhindern Herr Kollege
Emmerich und ja
ja ist das jetzt noch die Beantwortung
die Frage was passiert wenn jemand
asylbegehrt dann in der Tat wenn er noch
nicht in seinem bisherigen EU-Staat in
dem man sich aufgehalten hat bereits
einen Asylantrag gestellt hat dann in
der Tat hat er das Recht nach
gegenwärtige Rechtslage in Deutschland
ein Asyl gesucht zu stellen und geprüft
zu werden aber Frau Ministerin in ihrer
Antwort steht auch dass dies an der
Grenze zu Österreich nur bei 12 Prozent
der Menschen die illegal festgestellt
worden waren der Fall war bei allen
anderen eben nicht bei den anderen
Grenzen wissen wir es nicht Frau
Innenministerin und deswegen ist auch
das ein Grund dafür warum wir diese
stationären Grenzkontrollen brauchen nur
mit Schleierfahndung können wir das
nicht feststellen eine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
wir haben jetzt noch zwei Fragen einmal
von Frau Bünger von der Fraktion Die
Linke und Frauen kadur Bündnis 90 die
Grünen ich würde vorschlagen dass wir
die beide hintereinander stellen und sie
die dann gemeinsam beantworten bitte
weil sie sich gerade auf eine Anfrage
von uns berufen und
weil es um die Situation an der
deutsch-österreichischen Grenze geht und
sie das mit der Situation an der
polnisch-deutschen Grenze verglichen
haben wir fragen dazu nach und wir haben
dazu sehr interessante
Antworten bekommen man beruft sich da
nämlich auf einen Abkommen von 1961 als
würde man den den schengender Grenzraum
gar nicht kennen und aus unserer Sicht
stellt sich eher die Frage ob die
Bundespolizei vor Ort an der Grenze
nicht vielleicht Asylgesuche
überhört hat dass diese gestellt wurden
weil es stellt sich doch die Frage warum
sollte die Anzahl an einer
binnengrenze
deutsch-österreichische Grenze die
Anzahl an asylsuchen geringer sein als
an der polnisch deutschen Grenze und ich
frage mich und ich frage sie wie sie die
Frage beantworten weil ich stelle mir
die Frage wie kann das mit
rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln möglich sein
wir gehen davon aus dass dort auch
rechtswidrige Zurückweisung
stattgefunden haben
vielen Dank und Frau kador bitte
vielen Dank Herr Kollege drum für ihre
Bereitschaft sie hatten ja gerade schon
mal wenigstens angedeutet es ist keine
einfachen Lösung gibt das ist ja schon
mal einen Schritt nach vorne gut dass
sie es endlich mal sagen ich hätte gerne
klare und konkrete Antwort von Ihnen
wenn eine sogenannte
oberintegrationsgrenze angelangt ist
wenn wir da sind egal bei welcher Zahl
was machen wir mit der 1 2 3 5 6 20
Personen was machen sie was ist ihr
konkret auf ja wir wollen mal konkrete
Antworten von Ihnen hören dann sagen Sie
uns doch bitte mal was konkret zu tun
ist
Frau Kollegin Frau Kollegah danke
danke für die Frage aber sie beinhaltet
die Unterstellung dass uns unsere
Bundespolizistin und Bundespolizisten
die eine schwierige Aufgabe an der
Grenze machen bewusst Rechtswidrigkeiten
und da verwahre ich mich dagegen
gegenüber unseren bundespolizistischen
Bundespolizisten und wenn das der Fall
wäre wir haben jetzt seit acht Jahren
diese bienengrenzkontrollen dann hätten
es bestimmt sie pRO ASYL oder sonst
irgendjemand geschafft dieses
herauszufinden es gibt keinerlei
Hinweise dafür Frau kolleginer sie
behaupten hier ohne dass sie eine
entsprechende Tatsachen Grundlage haben
und das ist nicht seriös
und Frau Kollegen Kato ich habe gerade
vorhin schon was zu dem Thema Obergrenze
gesagt und habe damit das bestätigt was
ihre Kolleginnen Eckert gerade vorhin
ist sie noch da
ja Entschuldigung die Frau Kollegin
sorry Kollegen Gühring Eckart gerade
vorhin gesagt hat eine Obergrenze als
Richtschnur und als solche hatten wir es
auch im letzten Koalition eine hören Sie
doch einfach zu also nochmal sie müssen
schon zuhören meine Antwort dann
versuchen sie zu verstehen entweder das
gelingt ihn aus gelingt ihnen nicht aber
das ist dann eher ihr Problem wir
brauchen eine Obergrenze als Richtschnur
des politischen Handelns diese hatten
wir im Koalitionsvertrag ich wiederhole
mich jetzt hier zum dritten Mal und
diese Richtschnur muss dann mit
Maßnahmen mit handeln mit Positionen
unterlegt werden das ist genau das
Gegenteil zu dem was diese
Ampelkoalition dass die Innenministerin
macht sie haben eine Richtschnur zum
Eröffnen mit ihrem Paradigmenwechsel sie
haben eine Richtschnur zum Öffnen mit
ihrem Paradigmenwechsel und wenn sie
dann die Maßnahmen machen beispielsweise
all die Maßnahmen die wir heute in
unserem Antrag vorlegen dann werden
unter diese 200.000 wenn wir uns darauf
reinigen können unter diese 200.000
kommen das ist frau Kollegin Cador ich
hoffe Sie haben es jetzt verstanden das
ist die
Zielsetzung einer Richtschnur
Liebe
erleben eine gravierende Spaltung
unserer Gesellschaft das hat
das hat mit ihrer Politik zu tun weil es
hat sich verändert Herr Kollege Pahlke
wenn Sie wenn es nur an uns liegen würde
das kann ja nicht sein es hat sich
verändert durch ihr Handeln durch ihre
Kollegen
erkennen Sie dieses drehen sie um weil
sonst Schaden sie dauerhaft Deutschland
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die nächste Rednerin ist Dr anveruschka
Jurisch für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es freut mich
dass die Union ihrer Aufgabe als
konstruktiver Opposition mal nachkommt
und einige Vorschläge jetzt mit dem
Blick auf das Thema Migration
eingebracht hat aber dass das ganze dann
so großspurig für aus meiner Sicht als
Deutschland packt eingetütet und
verkauft wird finde ich ehrlich gesagt
so ein bisschen kryptisch aber so ist
das ja manchmal mit neuen
außenauftritten
aber ich habe mir ihren Antrag natürlich
vor allem auch inhaltlich angeschaut und
da ist einiges drin was ich okay finde
wo ich sage da müssen wir jetzt als
Regierungsparteien uns geschlossen
dahinter klären und mein Kollege
Konstantin cooler hat das ja auch schon
gesagt die Reform des europäischen
Asylsystems muss geschlossen weiter
betrieben werden und da hat unsere
Innenministerin sehr gut vorgespurt die
Rückführung in der Praxis müssen besser
umgesetzbar gemacht werden und dafür
muss der Ausreise Gewahrsam verlängert
werden Georgien und Moldau müssen zu
sicheren Herkunftsstaaten erklärt werden
und wir sollten überlegen welche
weiteren dazu kommen können
dann gibt es aber Punkte da habe ich mir
die Augen gerieben sie fordern mehr
migrationsabkommen als ein Mittel der
Wahl ja sehr richtig aber da muss ich
mich schon fragen warum haben Sie dieses
Instrument seiner Zeit nicht selber
konsequent angewendet neben einem
Abkommen mit Guinea gibt es aus ihrer
Regierungszeit nichts wir sind damit
Indien Georgien Moldau und vielen
weiteren in der Pipeline schon nach
einem Jahr von Joachim stamp im Amt sehr
viel weiter und das ist gut so
und dann diese Spiegelfechterei mit
diesen stationären Grenzkontrollen
zwischen Bayern und Österreich gibt es
wenn bin Grenzkontrollen im Moment aber
wo bleibt denn die Reduktion der
irregulären Migration in Bayern und auch
der südanträge vor allem in diesem Jahr
in Bayern über ein Viertel mehr
Asylanträge als im Vorjahreszeitraum und
über eine über die Hälfte mehr
schlepperfälle und das viele der
Menschen die an der Grenze zu Bayern
übrigens vor allem Afghanen die dann
wieder nach Österreich gehen abgewiesen
werden dann einfach über die Schweiz
einreisen sagen sie nicht und auch nicht
dass es völlig unmöglich und sinnlos ist
alle deutschen Grenzen stationär zu
kontrollieren hören Sie also in Bayern
auf mit ihrem ST Florians Prinzip auch
und streuen Sie den Menschen keinen Sand
in die Augen
und in ihrem Papier fehlt aber auch eins
ich vermisse auch nur ein positives Wort
zum Thema arbeitseinwanderung und zum
Thema Akzeptanz von Migration als
Standortfaktor und als
gesellschaftlicher Faktor für unser Land
frage sie wo ist die Volkspartei
geblieben die auch die bei uns lebenden
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
vertritt
wo ist die Partei mit
Wirtschaftskompetenz geblieben die
verstanden hätte dass unsere Unternehmen
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland brauchen und
auch wollen das ist doch peinlich
aber es fehlt noch mehr
sie sagen nicht dass auch die Länder in
der Pflicht sind und ein Beitrag leisten
können wohlgemerkt auch die
unionsgeführten Länder dass die Länder
ausreichend Personal und Ausreise
gewahrsamsätze bereitstellen müssen das
ist in den Ländern keine Sinn freien
abstiebestopps abschiebestopps geben
darf wie die Winterpause hier im Land
Berlin
und ihr Papier ist auch bemerkenswert
einfallslos
bemerkenswert einfallslos was der Bund
oder die EU noch machen könnten ich
möchte jetzt mal nicht ihren Job machen
aber hier noch ein paar Gedanken wir
brauchen eine neue
eu-türkei-vereinbarung wir müssen
darüber reden wie die
anerkennungspraktiken innerhalb der
Europäischen Union angeglichen werden
können und auch wie lange es welche Art
von Sozialleistung für geflüchtete gibt
das muss angeglichen werden also in
ihrem Papier gibt es einige Punkte bei
denen wir als FDP mitgehen können und
schön auch dass sie zugeben dass es
keine Generallösung gibt einiges in
ihrem Papier ist schief vieles vieles
fehlt das ist kein Deutschland packt
aber lassen Sie uns gerne im
Innenausschuss weiter darüber
diskutieren und gemeinsam nach Lösungen
suchen vielen Dank
er sagte er Jurist für die FDP-Fraktion
als Mitglied im Innenausschuss denn
dieser Antrag der CDU-Fraktion der hier
diese Debatte zugrunde liegt der geht im
Anschluss in die Beratung in die
Ausschüsse
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Interessante an dem Fall
Aiwanger ist ja das bei der Entscheidung
ihm im Amt zu belassen oder ihn zu
entlassen nicht maßgeblich war was in
diesem Hass getriebenen schier
antisemitischen Holocaust
verherrlichenden Pamphlet gestanden hat
sondern dass die Abwägung entscheidend
war was bringt mehr an der
stimmungsrunde und einer Stimme und das
war die maßgebliche Leitlinie der
Entscheidung von Herrn Söder ich erlebe
gerade wie dieses Prinzip übertragen
wird auf die Migrationspolitik seitens
der Union nämlich darauf zu achten was
wohl schnell in größeren
stimmungsgewinnen gibt mit Hoffnung
daraus Stimmen gewinnen zu machen bei
den anstehenden Landtagswahlen ich sage
Ihnen es wird nicht gelingen und sie
wissen das viele zumindest in ihren rein
wissen genau dass dieser neue autoritäre
restriktive Kurs niemals zu Erfolg
führen wird wir erleben und wir sind
unintelligible und das muss man hier mal
benennen eines klaren Rechtsrucks der
Union selbst Herr Seehofer der ihr ja
euch häufig genannt wurde warnte uns
nicht nur von den überzogenen
Forderungen und treiben zu lassen
seitens der Unionsfraktion ich erinnere
mich noch genau nein er immerhin
argumentierte für das malte Abkommen er
hatte noch einen Blick für Seenotrettung
nichts davon hören wir heutzutage mehr
aus ihren offiziellen Reihen hinter den
Kulissen mag es anders aussehen neben
dem Rechtsruck aber ist noch etwas
erstaunlich dieser Deutschland packt der
Union zur Migration der ist doch nichts
anderes als eine Mogelpackung Migration
der Union er besteht aus Ansatzpunkten
und Maßnahmen die wir aber deutlich
detaillierter in der Ampel schon
angegangen sind oder noch an gegen
werden die angekündigt sind er besteht
aus populistischen Maßnahmen und er
besteht aus Scheinlösung das ist ihr
groß fertiger Deutschland packt und die
Mogelpackung geht noch weiter wenn sie
wirklich eine klare Alternative Antwort
sein wollten ein anderes Konzept ein
anderes Paradigma vertreten wollen warum
sagen Sie da nicht hier in diesem Antrag
jawohl Abschaffung ist in die neuen
asylrechtseinschränkungen des
reformverbotes das wäre eine klare Linie
fundamental falsch aber eine klare Linie
finden wir nicht ebenso wenig wie die
Obergrenze stattdessen finden wir und
das wieder besseres Wissen bei Ihnen die
Beschwörung von gänskontrollen im Wissen
das Schutz ersuchen das Aushebeln das
Zurückweisung Zurückschiebung eben nicht
möglich ist und wir finden auch zu
drittstaatenlösung nicht die
entscheidende Details macht das Land das
mit gilt die EMRK ist das Land wirklich
sicher macht die
internationale Behörde z.B HCR
entsprechende Lösung mit was dringend
notwendig wäre all das finden wir nicht
und fragen Sie sich um das zum Schluss
fragen sich einmal gibt es eigentlich
eine Union was ist die Union ist das
jetzt die CSU von Söder ist das was die
Bundestagsfraktion hier vorträgt oder
ist das die Union von Herrn wüst die
tagtäglich ganz andere Töne äußert die
gegenteilig agiert und die noch für
seinen Kurs steht den wir unter anderem
Merkel erlebt haben haben wir hier zwei
Union gibt es mehrere Kurse ihrer Partei
oder ist es ja womöglich so dass sie
diese Vielstimmigkeit ganz gut finden
weil man ja da mehr Stimmen abgreifen
kann
kurz gesagt wir haben hier keine Lösung
von ihnen aber wir sehen deutlich ein
noch verborgenen fundamentalen Essenz in
der Migrationspolitik kümmern sie sich
darum und reden Sie mal in den eigenen
Reihen was hinter geschlossenen Türen
über diesen autoritären Rechtskurs
tatsächlich gedacht wird wir sehen uns
wieder nach den Landtagswahlen
war das für die SPD der Demokratie
politische Sprecher die Union bringt
Vorschläge einem illegale Einwanderung
zu begrenzen nicht drin das hat er
gelernt angesprochen tatsächlich das was
Markus Söder ja formuliert hat eine
integrationsobergrenze von 200.000
Migranten pro Jahr das findet sich
beispielsweise nicht in diesem Antrag
der Unionsfraktion robertal jetzt als
Fraktionslose Abgeordneter Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
dieser
deutschland-pakt in der
Migrationspolitik ist ja von Herrn
Schulz vorgeschlagen worden die CDU hat
das aufgegriffen aber was die CDU
vorgelegt hat wird keine Änderung in der
Substanz bringen weil es weichgespült
ist und klare Forderungen dort auch
nicht enthalten sind
schätzungsweise 80 Milliarden Euro
jährlich kostet die bis heute
fortdauernde Grenzöffnung das ist das
Geld was uns an jeder Ecke im Haushalt
fehlt was es bei allen sozialen
Forderungen und Problemen fehlt in
unserem Land der von der
bei der Union gilt dass man sich auf das
Wort von Merkel fokussiert hat man kann
sich nicht darauf verlassen dass das was
vor den Wahlen gesagt wird auch nach den
Wahlen gilt wer hat die Grenzen geöffnet
und das Recht gebrochen das war Frau
Merkel und die Union wer hat den
un-migrationspakt ausgehandelt und im
Bundestag beschlossen das war Frau
Merkel und die Union und wenn die Grünen
jetzt auch noch angeblich schnellere
Abschiebungen fordern zeigt das nur dass
das schweren Theater der Altparteien
wirklich komplett geworden ist
wissen Sie was ich langsam meine im
Fazit dieser Diskussion
5000 Migranten werden von 12 Schiffen
die NGOs aufsammeln und zwar die
unterstützt werden mit deutschen
Steuergeldern die nämlich zwei Millionen
zum Beispiel an eine solche
ngo-organisation weiter gibt Frau
bärbock die werden dort aufgesammelt
jeden Tag angeliefert die Lampedusa und
kommen dann nach Deutschland und dann
Quellen bei uns die Lager über wissen
Sie was Ihnen fehlt sie haben keine
Empathie für das deutsche Volk sie haben
nur Empathie für andere Leute die hier
Unterschlupfen aber sie kümmert
überhaupt nicht dass bei uns Leute
Flaschenpfand sammeln das
Messerstechereien stattfinden dass die
Bevölkerung Aufruhr ist sie regieren mit
über 80% Ablehnung gegen unser Volk
stellen Sie diese sukzessive Deutschland
Zerstörung endlich habt machen Sie mal
was wir richtiges nämlich für unsere
Bevölkerung erinnern sich an den Spruch
der über diesen Reichstag dem deutschen
Volker sind Sie verpflichtet aber nicht
ihrer falschen Migrationspolitik und
ihrer schrittweisen Zerstörung dieses
Landes danke
Robert fahle war das er ist für die AFD
in den Bundestag eingezogen sitzt jetzt
aber als fraktionsloses Mitglied hier im
Hohen Haus Josef Oster hören wir jetzt
von der Unionsfraktion
verehrte Frau Präsidentin verirrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also die
Debatte am heutigen Vormittag lässt mich
einigermaßen fassungslos zurück
also einige Wortbeiträge aus der
Koalition und auch der Wortbeitrag der
Ministerin sind der Lage vollkommen
unangemessen ich will noch mal an den
Ausgangspunkt der Debatte erinnern der
Kanzler vwo der Kanzler schlägt einen
Pakt für Deutschland vor in der
Migrationspolitik und das ist ja eine
durchaus sinnvolle Initiative selten
genug bei unserem Bundeskanzler und das
greifen wir mit wirklich konstruktiven
Vorschlägen auf und was hören wir dazu
aus der Reihe aus den Reihen der
Koalition von den Rednerinnen und
Rednern der Koalition
Ignoranz und pure Realitätsverweigerung
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
müsste doch mittlerweile jeden klar sein
dass es so wie es ist nicht bleiben kann
dass wir Steuerung und vor allen Dingen
Begrenzung brauchen es müsste doch
Konsens sein dass bei aller
Hilfsbereitschaft in unserem Land zum
Glück weiterhin gibt wir so nicht
weitermachen können die migrationszahlen
sind viel zu hoch sie überfordern uns
organisatorisch und sie überfordern uns
gesellschaftlich aber verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen abseits der
vielen wirklich konstruktiven Vorschläge
die wir in unserem Antrag gemacht haben
müssen meines Erachtens zwei
grundsätzliche Dinge passieren zum einen
müssen sich die Grünen von einer
Grundhaltung verabschieden eine
Grundhaltung die da lautet jede Form von
Migration ist gut für Deutschland das
ist falsch das ist etwas was wir uns
nicht leisten können und das ist nicht
gut für unser Land verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und darüber hinaus muss Olaf Scholz
seine Passivität in dieser Frage endlich
Aufgeben der Bundeskanzler muss das
Thema der migrationskrise endlich zur
Chefsache machen zur Chefsache in der
nationalen Politik und zur Chefsache
auch in der europäischen Politik und ich
will dazu sagen auch eine
bundesaußenministerin sollte sich nicht
zu fein sein in dieser Sache auch mal
diplomatische Aktivitäten zu entfalten
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist jetzt die Stunde des Bundeskanzlers
so schwer ihm das fallen mag aber es
geht um nicht weniger als um den
gesellschaftlichen Frieden in unserem
Land
zum Abschluss dieser Debatte erhält
Gülistan Yüksel für die SPD-Fraktion das
Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren auf den
Tribünen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
beim Lesen des union-antrages habe ich
mich doch sehr gewundert sie wollen die
irreguläre Migration stoppen und dann
kein Wort von ihrer so heiß geliebten
Obergrenze oder wie ihr bayerischer
Ministerpräsident des neuerdings zu
verkaufen versucht Integrationsgrenze es
scheint dass das bayerische Bierzelt
nicht nur die Rhetorik sondern auch den
Inhalt der Forderungen verändert das ist
einfach unehrlich und unglaubwürdig
unaufrichtig ist auch die Forderung
selbst ob nun Obergrenze oder
Integrationsgrenze beides ist reine
Symbolpolitik und mit Symbolpolitik
kennen sie sich ja aus davon gibt es ja
einiges in ihrem Antrag ich empfehle
ihnen lesen Sie die Stellungnahme der
Gewerkschaft der Polizei zu den von
Ihnen so leidenschaftlich geforderten
Grenzkontrollen dort steht das
stationäre Grenzkontrolle nicht zu einer
Reduzierung der Flüchtlingsaufnahme
führen von einem politisch motivierten
Trugschluss spricht hier die GdP
Gewerkschaft der Polizei
es zeigt sich also auch hier betreiben
sie Augenwischerei
effektiver
reflektiver ist im Sinne einer
geordneten Migration die
Schleierfahndung an den deutschen
Grenzen genau diese hat unsere
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
intensiviert und so bereits sehr
erfolgreich zu Bekämpfung der
schleuserkriminalität beigetragen
aber ich gebe zu ihr Antrag enthält
nicht nur Scheinlösungen einige ihrer
Forderungen sind sogar gut denn sie
wiederholen in ihrem Antrag die
mpk-beschlüsse auf die sich Bund und
Länder geeinigt haben das freut uns
natürlich denn diese Punkte setzen wir
in der Regierung bereits um
wir bekämpfen nicht nur die
schleuserkriminalität wer Stärken auch
die rückkehrhilfen wir erweitern die
Listen der sicheren Herkunftsstaaten wir
verhandeln migrationsabkommen und halten
dafür erstmals einen Sonderbeauftragten
eingesetzt meine Kollegen ist ja darauf
eingegangen um ganz wesentlich wir haben
auf europäischer Ebene den Grundstein
dafür gelegt das geflüchtete innerhalb
der EU künftig endlich solidarisch
verteilt werden
schon das ist ein Erfolg von Nancy Feser
denn über 16 Jahre kein Innenminister
der Union zustande gebracht hat
wie auch wenn bei ihnen damals wie heute
populistische Symbolpolitik im
Vordergrund steht meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ob auch nationaler oder
internationaler Ebene die
Bundesregierung bietet wirkungsvolle
Lösungen in der Migrationspolitik und
setzt diese mit unseren europäischen
Partnern um und darauf kommt es an denn
die Bekämpfung der irregulären Migration
kann nur gemeinsam gelingen herzlichen
Dank
war das für die SPD-Fraktion der letzte
Rednerin zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt ja
über die Migrationspolitik wurde sich
hier auf Grundlage des Antrags der Union
zu einem deutschlandpackt in der
Migrationspolitik hier debattiert es war
zum Teil eine Debatte durchaus mit
scharfen Tönen die unionsfraktionen hat
sich zwar grundsätzlich bereit erklärt
mit der Koalition nach Lösung zu suchen
um die Zahl der
eu-leeren Migranten zu reduzieren aber
der landesgruppenchef der CSU Alexander
doberin der hat hier eine Debatte der
Regierung zumindest vorgeworfen dass sie
die erforderlichen Maßnahmen blockieren
würde die bundesinnenministerin wiederum
nennt sie Faser die hat das hier
zurückgewiesen und der Union im Gegenzug
Populismus vorgeworfen also die Debatte
geht natürlich weiter auf deutscher
Ebene auf europäischer Ebene vor allem
auch und dieser Antrag der wird
zumindest im Innenausschuss des
Bundestages weiter debattiert
so jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Tag
Tagesordnungspunkt
[Musik]
und die AFD enthält sich es gab noch
eine kleine Verzögerung jetzt war ich
etwas zu schnell
wir stimmen heute über den Antrag auf
Drucksache 84.04 nicht in der Sache
jetzt gab es noch Verzeihung den Antrag
dass man diesen Antrag der Union
wiederum sofort abstimmen möge aber das
hat hier keine Mehrheit gefunden
deswegen bleibt es dabei wie angekündigt
die Beratung über diese Vorschläge der
cdu/csu-fraktion die wird also im
Ausschuss beispielsweise im
Innenausschuss federführend fortgesetzt
so dann kommen wir aber jetzt zum
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es
um die Sozialpolitik
seit Beginn dieses Jahres da hat ja das
Bürgergeld hat vier abgelöst diese
Reform betrifft ungefähr 5 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland die Leistungen
beziehen aus dieser
bürgergeldreform ergeben sich auch
Änderungen im verschiedene Art und Weise
in den Sozialgesetzbüchern im zwölften
im 14 Sozialgesetzbuch hier wird es
etwas technisch
das betrifft beispielsweise konkret wie
es um die Angleichung bei
Berücksichtigung von Einkommen geht also
dazu liegt ein Gesetzentwurf vor
sozusagen im Nachgang zum Bürgergeld das
noch anzugleichen und verschiedene sind
Sozialgesetzbuch was noch geregelt
werden muss es gibt auch zwei Anträge
der afd-fraktion und der Linksfraktion
dazu gleich in der Debatte mehr hören
wir jetzt erst zum Auftakt die
parlamentarische